In today's lecture,
we'll examine the concept of nominal consideration.
Nominal consideration is the payment of a very small sum such as $1 to satisfy
the contracts consideration requirement.
As we will see,
while many courts reject the idea that nominal consideration is sufficient for a
contract,
the issue remains very contentious.
First,
let's take a look at the basic argument for why nominal consideration should be
sufficient for a contract.
It's well established that courts usually refrain from judging the fairness of
the bargain that the parties have struck.
In other words,
courts don't inquire into the adequacy of consideration whether the quid was
roughly the same value as the quo.
In a quid pro quo arrangement under a strict reading of this rule,
payment of a very small sum should be enough to satisfy the consideration
requirement.
The approach,
this kind of approach was first advocated by the first restatement restatement
of contracts,
which said,
a promise to pay $1 in exchange for a piece of land called black acre worth
$5,000 was adequate consideration.
However,
it's not clear that the first restatements position on nominal consideration was
supported by case law.
When discussing nominal consideration,
uh,
the example of a peppercorn is often used as a parent,
dogmatic,
uh,
instance,
of the smallest thing that one could give in return,
uh,
for someone else's promise.
Some contracts have used a literal peppercorn as the promise consideration.
The Masonic Lodge of Saint George's in Bermuda rents a lodge from the governor
of Bermuda using an annual,
some of the single peppercorn.
The more widely accepted approach today rejects nominal consideration has been
sufficient consideration deeming it insufficient for creating a contract.
Contemporary courts are unlikely to dismiss attempts to dress up a gift with
false recitals of consideration or exchange of a nominal sum.
While a peppercorn satisfies the older legal detriment definition of
consideration,
it doesn't satisfy the more modern bargained for or inducement conception of
consideration.
The second restatement states that courts should be suspicious of contracts
where a large disparity in value exists.
The disparity in May indicate that the consideration was not in fact bargained
for,
but was a mere formality or pretense of a bargain under the widely accepted
modern rule,
sham or nominal consideration does not satisfy the requirement of a contract.
So under the restatement,
would the black acre example of $1 for a $5,000 piece of property,
uh,
be a valid contract.
Recall the earlier black acre example where someone offered $5,000 piece of land
in exchange for just $1 following the second restatement principles with this
black Acre contract be valid?
Well,
the answer is no.
In fact,
the second restatement clearly states that the black acre example is sham
consideration resulting in no contract.
One case which illustrates the widely accepted contemporary approach is Edwin
Farnum,
uh,
green case or the in what's called in Ray Green.
This case involved a defendant named green,
a married man who lived for several years with the plaintiff,
a woman who was not his wife.
When the two separated,
they entered into a written agreement under seal requiring the defendant to a
pay plaintiff $1,000 per month for the rest of their joint lives and be maintain
a hundred thousand dollar life insurance policy on his life with plaintiff as
the beneficiary and exchange the plaintiff release defendant from all claims she
had against him and paid him a $1 the agreement specified that the consideration
given was $1 quote and other good and valuable consideration.
The court made two important findings.
First,
it rejected the idea that $1 is sufficient consideration.
Second,
it held that it's not enough for parties to merely recite that there is good and
valuable consideration.
Consideration must be actually present for a contract to be valid.
Let's take a look at the history of of different approaches to nominal
consideration.
Nominal nominal consideration can be viewed as a sort of formality.
It's a sign of the party's intent to achieve a certain legal result.
Contracting parties have historically used many different formalities to seal
their deals,
sometimes as a matter of customs and sometimes to comply with legal
requirements.
As we find in the Bible,
Abraham established a covenant with God by the scorching of a three year old
heifer,
a three year old goat and the three year old ram and a turtle,
dove and a pigeon.
And of course,
contracting parties today often end to deal with a handshake.
All of these conventions reflect the traditional employment of formalities to
signal seriousness or enforceability.
And important example of legal formality was the rope and was the Roman a stip
Bellagio,
a stipulation or stipulation under the Justinian code.
Some agreements would be enforced,
only have one side requested performance prefaced by spawn deaths nay and the
other side responded using the words spawn Deo meaning,
uh,
respectively.
Do you promise?
And then I do promise without those recitations,
the deal wouldn't be legally enforceable.
Lon Fuller in a classic article called consideration and form suggested that
legal formalities serve evidentiary cautionary and channeling function,
uh,
functions and that they can be good formalities while they seem like they're
arid and arbitrary.
They can serve an evidentiary function because they provide others,
uh,
including courts with information about the party's intention.
They provide a cautionary function like form of warnings.
Do you really want to reform at your hard drive by slowing down and inducing
more deliberation by the potential contractors?
And finally,
formalities might channel parties toward different types of accountability.
Friends might prefer non legal consequences.
Business partners might prefer legally enforceable contracts.
At common law,
the formality needed to establish a contract was the seal in early days.
The seal was a wax substance attached to the document.
Later,
uh,
paper wafer was often used or simply written with the words under seal or Ls,
which was the Latin for locus sigale meaning in the place of the seal,
the writ of covenant,
which was used to enforce,
enforce certain agreements,
conditioned enforcement on the existing of uh,
writing under seal.
The legal effect did not derive from the substance of the agreement whether it
was bargained for exchange,
but from the formal mode in which the promise was cast in the past at the common
law and agreement under seal was binding without consideration if it was in
writing and sealed and the document containing the promise was delivered.
And number three that the promise and the promise see were named in the document
during the early 20th century.
Many US states passed statutes that radically reduced the legal effect of a
sealed writing or reducing their legal enforceability.
Some states abolish the seal entirely.
This approach is reflected in the UCC two dash two oh three which makes it clear
that every effect of the seal which relates to sealed instruments as such is
wiped out in so far as contracts for sale of goods are concerned,
other state legislature's retain the seal,
but provided that lack of consideration could remain a defense to sealed
instruments.
This is what happened in the green case we discussed earlier.
Other states have adopted other modifications such as providing a longer statute
of limitation for contracts under seal for the practitioner.
This means that it's crucial to know the effect of the seal and the jurisdiction
in which you're working.
The broad abolition of the seal or the enforceability of promises under seal has
had its costs.
Many regard the seal as a useful device if for no other reason that it provided
a convenient method of making legally binding gratuitous promises.
It was inevitable that attention would be given to filling this vacuum and it
was most natural to turn to the most common form of formality,
which is the signed writing in 1925 largely at the instigation of of Williston,
the National Conference of Commissioners on uniform state laws approved a draft
of the uniform written obligation act.
The recommended statute was a model of brevity.
It essentially stated that a written agreement shall not be invalidated for a
lack of consideration as long as the parties are explicit that they want to be
legally bound.
Uh,
I'm a big fan of this act,
but the proposal has met with a singular lack of success.
Only Pennsylvania has adopted and retained the act,
which means that in the Quaker state,
consideration is not a mandatory mandatory requirement for enforcing promises.
The decline of seal has not meant the complete abandonment of legal formalities.
The a uniform commercial code provides three examples in which assigned writing
can serve as a substitute for consideration.
Section one three Oh six covers waver or renunciation of claims of right after
breach and it provides that any claim or right arising out of an alleged breach
can be discharged without consideration by a written waiver or renunciation.
Signed and delivered by the aggrieved party.
Section two Dash Two oh five discusses a firm offer which are offers that cannot
be revoked before acceptance and it gives conditions under which a firm offer
can be enforced even without consideration.
And finally,
section two two oh nine says that an agreement modifying a contract needs no
consideration to be binding.
Here are some tips for making sure that your contracts pass the consideration
test
first.
You can explicitly have your contracts say that the parties intend to be this
contract to be legally enforceable and you might even try to say that it's going
to be governed by the law of Pennsylvania,
which is adopted this a written obligation act.
Secondly,
you can include in the contract a return promise that is hard to value.
Instead of saying that $1 is the valuable consideration,
have the promise he promised to as in return paint or sing something that is
hard to value.
And finally,
as a tip,
you might have,
uh,
increased the values of both sides while a hundred to one disparity in value
might not be enforced.
Attend to one disparity can be created by increasing the promises on both sides.
So instead of promising an iPhone in exchange for a peppercorn promise,
an I phone plus a week of groceries in exchange for $200 in a personal portrait.
In this module,
we have examined the concept of nominal consideration.
Nominal consideration can be viewed as a formality.
Under common law contract was once binding as long as it has a seal on it.
That was the old common law.
Regardless of whether there was consideration under the legal detriment,
conception of consideration,
even a peppercorn would be sufficient consideration.
One contemporary attempt at replicating the effect of the seal has been the
modern written obligation act,
but it's been only passed in Pennsylvania.
Most contemporary jurisdictions apply the rule that nominal consideration is
insufficient for a contract because it's not bargained for.
It's just the pretense of a bargain.